when the taliban took over kabul a
vancouver-based group canadian women for
afghan women quickly tried to get its 25
afghan employees and families out of the
country they'd been there promoting the
rights of women and girls but with last
summer's election just underway it
became difficult to reach canadian
immigration officials within days it was
clear that it wasn't business as usual
people were unavailable everything just
kind of froze for a couple of months
actually and that had real implications
for people's lives in fact documents
obtained by global news through several
access to information requests show a
government scrambling in the midst of an
election and overwhelmed by the flood of
requests for help ninety thousand emails
had piled up by mid-august and just one
in five phone calls placed by desperate
afghans to canadian officials was being
answered
five of the 25 families employed by
canadian women for afghan women did get
out but 20 families are still there and
it's why lauren oates was in tajikistan
on the afghan border trying to help i've
seen no progress at all on any of my
colleagues files
and it's getting
exceedingly dangerous for them i mean
our office has been visited by the
taliban
we've had many scary incidents and the
clock is ticking some are now worried
canada does not have the capacity to
handle a refugee crisis like the one in
ukraine and the still urgent crisis in
afghanistan
canada's immigration minister says it
does it's an enormous challenge we're
asking the system to do more than it's
ever been required to do at a time it's
already facing pressures uh but can we
do it i don't think we have a choice but
to do it one of the themes in thursday's
budget sources tell us is what they're
calling canada in the world and that's
taking the mean more defense spending
but advocates tell us they hope canada
in the world also means more spending on
refugees and foreign aid donna
david aiken in ottawa thank you